[Music]
right there
what's up cody chillin in a z how you
doing i'm good man back on the field
how i feel to be a champion best feeling
in the world bro
when it happens you don't even worry
about personal records you don't worry
about how you did during the regular
season like none of that matters
it's just straight up all about the ring
and celebrating with with your boys and
your teammates
that's what's up man how long you been
playing assassin creed i played it back
in the day
and i'm actually i'm in the game it was
crazy i did motion sensor
up on the big screen i had my actual
like viking warrior up there
so i felt like i was the the warrior the
names other sluggerson
i had did a test run no i didn't want to
leave out of there they had they had to
get me
take command oh i got there i got it
he down oh
and i gotta mention my my axe too you
got me right on the axe
and we got a note from one goat to
another do you accept my way
of the vikings challenge get three
bull's eyes on 10 tries
you win
oh i thought i know i just did maybe i
can get you in the game
cody bellinger i set up your challenge
so put me in the game
what's up vr it's chef cook checking in
accepting the exploring challenge for
assassin creed valhalla practice over
game time
i got this
let's go
oh i got him what
let's go let's go cody
you know i had this in the bag already
so you know i had i had to do what i had
to do
so i had a great time i had a blast i
killed the axe challenge
it's time for me to go
[Music]
write your viking saga on the all-new
xbox